hi everyone my name is Sabi I'm going to
be talking about a joint work with
Vishnu William and Daniel called Low
stabilizer complexity Quantum states are
not pseudorandom
so we're going to start with a little
background in Quantum Computing and
Quantum information
so the way we describe the state
of an end qubit system is with a two to
the N dimensional complex unit vector
this might be a familiar way of writing
such a vector we have a vector B that's
a combination
of standard basis States the norm is
ones it's the unit vector and the
coefficients are complex
the first notational change we make
is indexing over this base with bit
strings
and we denote column vectors
with
this cat notation
and if we take the conjugate transpose
of a KET we get a bra denoted like this
and the inner product between two
vectors
is denoted this way and this is the
braquette notation that's used in
quantum mechanics and Quantum computing
Evolution from one state to another is
described by a two to the N by 2 to the
N unitary Matrix or Quantum circuit
and any Quantum circuit can be
implemented with a universal gate set so
just like a Boolean function can be
implemented with and or not Gates or
nand Gates or whatever
there are also many Quantum gate sets
that are Universal
that can Implement a general Quantum
circuit U
an example of a universal gate set is
the Clifford plus T gate set
this is going to be this Gates that's
going to be relevant for this entire
talk
and the Clifford part of the gate set is
made up of these three gates the
Clifford Gates these are the hadamard
the phase gate and the controlled knot
gate or the C naught gate
the hadamarden phase are single qubit
Gates
and the C naught gate was a two qubit
gate
and the T part of this Kate set is just
the T gate a single qubit gate
and together the Clifford plus T gate
set is universal for Quantum computation
so we're going to spend a little time
talking about the Clifford uh in t kit
set uh starting with the Clifford Gates
so any Quantum circuit that's comprised
entirely of hadamard phase and C naught
Gates is called a Clifford circuit
a
Quantum State that's reachable from the
all zero basis state by applying
Clifford circuits is called the
stabilizer State and there's roughly 2
to the N squared stabilizer States
uh the stabilizer States and Clifford
circuits are variable studied classes of
states and circuits
just to give you a sense of some of the
properties and applications these have
found
uh stabilizer States exhibit
the quantum mechanical properties
superposition and entanglement
and Quantum protocols like teleportation
and super dense coding
um only make use of Clifford circuits
both Clifford State uh stabilizer States
and clippered circuits form three
designs so
roughly speaking they like they look
uniformly random in certain settings
and for these reasons in others
uh
stabilizer States and clippered circuits
show up in a bunch of different places
and Quantum Computing and Quantum
information first for error correcting
codes in the 90s and later for fault
tolerant Quantum computation for
randomized benchmarking
recently in learning and estimation
algorithms and a bunch of other stuff
and despite this we know that Clifford
circuits can be efficiently classically
simulated this is the goddessman canal
theorem
so uh
any Quantum algorithm that only makes
use of Clifford Gates is not going to
give you any speed up over classical
computing
and we also have efficient algorithms to
property test and to learn both Clifford
circuits and stabilizer States so we
have a pretty good handle on
on these objects
now the T gate we know uh with with the
additional ability to apply the T gate
we know that the gate set becomes
Universal and we also know that the
Clifford part is efficiently simulable
classically
and so given a Clifford plus T circuit
the number of T gates in that circuit
in a sense measures how complex the
circuit is
and we'll see later in the talk more
concretely that if you have a stabilizer
State when you apply more and more
t-gates that generally
takes your state farther and farther
away from being a stabilizer state
so that brings us to low stabilizer
complexity States
informally these are quantum states that
are in the neighborhood of stabilizer
States
the way we formalize this is with the
stabilizer fidelity
the stabilizer Fidelity of an N qubit
State PSI
is the maximum overlap that PSI has with
any stabilizer State fee
and we refer to Quantum states that have
non-negligible stabilizer fidelity
non-negligible overlap with some
stabilizer State as having low
stabilizer complexity so low stabilizer
complexity means that that a low
stabilizer complexity state is one that
is close to a stabilizer state
in terms of stabilizer Fidelity
so given that stabilizer states have
found many applications in Quantum
computing
and they
are very well understood what can be
said about low stabilizer complexity
States
specifically can we property test and
learn in this class these this class of
states
can we estimate the stabilizer Fidelity
of an unknown state
or better yet can we find the stabilizer
state that achieves the stabilizer
Fidelity so a stabilizer state with the
maximal overlap between a given
state
and it turns out we actually don't
really know much we don't have any
answers to these questions the best
known algorithms are just brute forcing
over all 2 to the N squared stabilizer
States
and it so it's possible that these
problems are all intractable
and one natural way to probe whether or
not that's the case is looking at the
Dual version of these problems which is
checking if these states are
computationally pseudo-random
this just means that there is no
efficient Quantum algorithm that could
distinguish a low stabilizer complexity
state from a random state
and if that happened to be the case then
of course there's no hope of efficiently
uh
answering any of these questions
and so in this work we kind of take the
first step towards
uh Perhaps Perhaps tackling these
questions
by showing that low stabilizer
complexity states are not pseudorandom
specifically we give an efficient
algorithm that distinguishes
um between the two so
given an N qubit State PSI that's
promised to be random or have low
stabilizer complexity we give an
efficient algorithm that decides which
and we also have a nice corollary uh
that little Omega log n t gates are
necessary for any clever plus T circuit
to prepare computational pseudo-random
Quantum States
and this is the first lower bound on
um the resources required to prepare
computationally pseudor in Quantum
States
so we're going to spend the rest of the
talk
um
talking about how we
showed these results
so for the efficient distinguishing
algorithm we need to introduce the vial
operators
so here we have the poly X and poly Z
matrices
and we Define the file operators in
terms of these matrices so we have a bit
string x with length 2N
the first n Bits we denote by a and then
the second half of the bit string we
denote by B
and the vial operator WX is then this
it's the tensor product of these two by
two matrices and at the end of the day
this ends up being
a 2 to the N by 2 to the N Matrix
it's easy to check that
um
these file Opera operators Square to the
identity so they have plus and minus one
eigenvalues
and except for the identity Matrix which
is
the vial operator you get when this x is
the zero string so except for the
identity Matrix
the eigenvectors of the vial operators
half of them have plus one eigenvalues
and half of them have minus one I cannot
use
okay and we can also Define a
distribution over the vowel operators
relative to some Quantum State PSI and
this is called the characteristic
distribution it's denoted by PSI
and
the probability that you sample some
vial operator is given by this
expression
and focusing in on this term
this is a number between 0 and 1.
and
this listen this expression is closer to
one when PSI is closer to being an
eigenvector of w x
so uh
if
PSI is closer to being an eigenvector of
a vial operator
then PSI will corresponding
correspondingly give that bio operator
more probability Mass
okay so we have this characteristic
distribution
this you know you can Define this
distribution check it's a distribution
but how does it fit into our algorithm
so in 2017 gross nizami and Walter
showed that if you have four copies of a
Quantum State PSI it's possible to
efficiently draw a sample from the
distribution QSI
which is this scaled convolution of PSI
with itself
okay and this is the main subroutine we
use in our algorithm
and what we do is we Define this
quantity ETA
which is the expectation
of scaled PSI
with respect to the measure Q PSI
and essentially what we do is we show
that
it's possible to efficiently estimate
Ada
and this kind of just boils down to
Computing an empirical mean
and then if ETA is large enough we
determine the state is low stabilizer
complexity
and if it's not we decide that the state
is heart random
now the technical part is showing that
ADA uh you know our choice of ADA
actually works so
that comes down to
two lemmas first that if
if PSI is random then Ada will be close
to zero
and if PSI has non-negligible stabilizer
fidelity
being it's a low stabilizer complexity
State then Ada will also be
non-negligible
and another way to write the second
Lemma is that with Ada you can get an
upper bound on the stabilizer Fidelity
of the quantum state
and this is the first property of a
Quantum state that we know of that you
can efficiently estimate and also gives
you some upper bound non-trivial upper
bound on the stabilizer fidelity
foreign
uses pretty standard techniques to prove
and I'm not going to give any details
about it in this presentation
but we're going to spend a little bit of
time talking about this second limo
so
the way we start the proof
is just applying some definition so Ada
we Define it to be
this like scaled expectation
and then just using the definition of q
PSI and the definition of expectation we
get this next line here remember that Q
PSI is like a scaled expectation of this
convolution which we we've dropped these
scaling factors
there and
by applying a few more basic steps
blanchardial's theorem
and a basic theorem for which you can
see a proof in Ryan O'Donnell's book on
Fourier analysis of Boolean functions we
show that ADA
is proportional to the three Norm of the
Fourier coefficients of PSI
and
the interesting thing here is that uh
this this the beginning of our analysis
is
turns out to just be the same as the
analysis that shows up in the blr
linearity test
and if you're not familiar with the blr
linearity test you can read chapter one
of Ryan O'Donnell's book which sort of
introduces the topic of Fourier analysis
of Boolean functions and
the first chapter concludes with this
blr linearity test
so why is this showing up
some intuition for why that's the case
first if
the first thing to note is that if site
is a stabilizer State then Q PSI is
equal to psi and and in that case ETA
will be equal to one
and if PSI is close to being a
stabilizer state it has a non-negligible
overlap
with some stabilizer State then Q PSI
remains well correlated with PSI
and the way we finish off this proof is
proving a lower bound on this three Norm
in terms of the stabilizer fidelity
and for details on that
um
best to refer to our manuscript
okay so how do we prove our corollary
the T gate lower Bound for preparing
pseudo-random Quantum States
so we need this fact that Quantum States
generated by Clifford plus T circuits
with order log n t Gates have inverse
poly stabilizer Fidelity
and the proof of that's fairly
straightforward
the first thing you do is argue that any
Clifford plus T circuit can be
decomposed into these interleaved layers
of Clifford Gates and a single T gate
and then you argue that
um
the Clifford layers don't change the
stabilizer Fidelity at all
and each layer
of T gate
decreases the stabilizer Fidelity by at
most some constant multiplicative factor
and that's it
foreign
so how do we use this to get our
corollary that little Omega log n t gets
are necessary to prepare a pseudo-random
Quantum state
first say
that PSI is prepared by a Clifford plus
T circuit with order log n t Gates
well then by the fact we just showed PSI
has low stabilizer complexity
and therefore the efficient
distinguishing algorithm we talked about
earlier can distinguish the state from
random
and so the psy cannot be pseudorandom
and we conclude that little Omega log
and T gates are necessary
so as far as open problems go one
natural Direction uh the
pseudo-randomness direction is to try to
improve these lower bounds in our paper
in the conclusion and in appendix B we
explain that new techniques are needed
the short story is that even if
it's possible there are some refinements
for an analysis
uh but even if those are made
the lower bound that we show will only
be improved by a constant Factor
in the learning and estimation Direction
it'd be nice to know if we can property
test or learn low stabilizer complexity
States
whether we can estimate stabilizer
fidelity
and whether we can find
stabilizer states that have large
overlap with a given Quantum State and
this might you know this sort of
this could be extended to
uh
understanding how close a general
unitary is to a Clifford circuit and
could lead you know there there may be
like for example decompositions where
you can decompose a Quantum circuit into
the Clifford part and the non-clifford
bark
uh
yeah and that's pretty much everything I
wanted to talk about
if you have any questions or comments
please feel free to reach out via email
thanks